dans votre épisode rediffusé samedi
dernier on se rend compte que lors de
l'arrivée de philippe etchebest votre
restaurant est plutôt vide ça vous
attriste énormément vous êtes un des
personnages qui a fait le plus parler
d'ailleurs dans cauchemar en cuisine et
vous finissez même par craquer regardez
bonjour monica c'est un moment du coeur
à 30 ans pau anglet 3 comme ça je me
suis bien mettre un peu de clients
ça suffit pas si j'y vais c'est bon je
vais m'installer là-bas
j'aurais milk déjà j'aurais aimé qu'il
soit là d'un projet plus de monde s'est
aussi montré un peu la vis pas donc
c'est pas toujours alors monique
amoureux déjà extrêmement triste à nous
raconter tout ce qui s'est passé ensuite
après l'arrivée de philippe etchebest
esseyric pour vous ça c'est plutôt très
mal passé première parce que l'émission
est scénarisé est ce qu'on vous a
demandé de rejouer des choses ou est-ce
que tout était écrit nous est pas du
tout vous avez été complètement naturel
non on est naturel vraiment plus en plus
modiques hawaïenne et pas voilà c'est
une expérience douloureuse pour elle
mais vous dit que vraiment nains et
naturelle et nous demande tout le temps
on est naturelle élevée
donc c'est tout naturellement il est
même pas ce qu'il y'a un truc aussi
qu'on a pu voir c'est que vous avez été
énervé aussi et c'est un cauchemar pour
vous parce que l'émission n'est pas à
portrait de vous très colérique parlant
mal à ses employés et c'est vrai que ça
ça vous a beaucoup peiné et derrière ça
a été très compliqué pour vous je vois
des ayant déjà que vous êtes très ému on
va revoir ce portrait et c'est vrai que
l'image qu'on a donnée d'elle dans
l'émission lui apporter et il lui a
porté préjudice regarder aller pisser le
crâne
allez sortez moi il faut il ya plein
d'épreuves de la femme et les deux fours
montano dans merde merde
papatakis aux sorties vers vous sentez
mois s'ajoute à un chic en bout le
prendre
[ __ ] ya deux volets qualitatifs tels
que les tétines tout foot est un mouton
tout cas c'est difficile mais ça vaut de
la merde [ __ ]
[Musique]
vous fait chier combien monsieur de
profiteroles n'a pas failli profiter à
mitiger pas conduit donc à des gangsters
merci alors monica juste vous a vu
l'extrait tout à l'heure et j'ai vu que
le restaurant était vide est ce que le
restaurant était vraiment ville où est
ce que c'est la prod qui vous a dit que
ce serait bien que le restaurant soit
vide et m'ont rien dit ils m'ont rien
dit oui je trouvais bizarre que ça soit
vide un mardi c'était le jour je
marchais le plus oui et par après coup
que tout a été fini il ya des clients
que monique sont venus pour manger
qu'ils ont été refusés à l'entrée qu'il
ne laissait pas rentrer à sanaa alors
voilà donc me voilà c'est pas moi c'est
ce qui m'a été dit par les clients je
parle pas la bouche s'envoler car déjà
été vie de madame ça il ya des jours où
on marche pas bien dit la mise en scène
ni clients demain je limite se
comprendre mais normal disent si c'est
un spectacle on se fait de la vo mais
voilà force est bon mais donc ils ont
bloqué les clients à l'entrée on leur
dira voilà il faut que le restaurant
soit vite parce que c'est normal et
c'est de la scénarisation donc la
réponse est est ce que l'émission est
scénarisé oui et c'est normal mais là
j'en ai chialé comme par hasard à chaque
épisode
le restaurant évident quand on ne baisse
vient faire le bilan et quand il le
remplit artificiellement en payant le en
payant leur pas à des gens qui sont
payés par m6 pour venir remplir le
restant des cons en europe 1
c'est dégueulasse c'est pas bon ça fait
longtemps que j'attends j'ai pas été
servi que ces tailles et jamais un
client content comme par hasard chaque
fois césarisé je viens je vous donnais
alors la parole après que vous avez
semblé mon pied j'ai eu une cliente m'a
dit monika j'ai dit que c'était pas bon
ils m'ont demandé de les lire quant à
elle me l'a dit qu'est ce qu'il s'est
passé parce qu'elle m'a dit que c'était
pas bon mais elle a dit c'était bon
après si l'on scène avec les gens qui
sont sales au pas je peux pas vous dire
parce connais et je me suis l'a fait on
est tellement pris par eux quand on voit
rien on a le temps de rien voir ne pas
réfléchir et une émission on n'a pas
l'habitude ils arrivent à l'improviste
on sait pas qu'ils soient ces graves
qu'ils ont demandé dit que c'était pas
bon pour le scénario dit tracy s'est
quand même vous écris tu fais partie de
l'écriture après voilà monica il pas qu
un gros problème aussi sur le tournage
avec un frigo qu'est ce qui s'est passé
à ça je sais pas s'ils sont au courant
parce qu'on a découvert sa part après
aussi hein parce que on est vraiment
vous faites la télé vous devez le savoir
mieux que nous et on est dans un monde
car pendant cinq jours on dirait qu'on
sort vous m'excusez le mot mais il ya
donné qu'on sorte notre core io n'est
plus une mine d'accord parce qu'on n'a
pas l'habitude on est tellement pris des
horaires et donc ils ont éteint un four
four pardon un frigo pendant le temps
qu'ont fait les entrevues au sol quand
on parle devant la caméra pour donner
nos sentiments et tout ce qui s'ensuit
ils s'étaient le four y avait la pâte à
pizza donc il a été et a longtemps on
s'est rendu compte prépare je crois
qu'ils sont rendus compte les matins
mais salariés à l'époque et ils m'ont
rien dit et moi je voulais comprendre
pourquoi cette pâte elle était pas bonne
parce qu'on avait c'est le mardi matin
et c'était pas possible qu'elle soit pas
bonne cet pape et il avait abandonné sur
l'amour intentionnellement les bruits
des cautionnements ils n'ont pas bien vu
alors après l'oréal aurait versé n'a
réfléchi appel à l'unité four à ses
parts dans ses frigos pour l'or l'or et
d'oporto porté au début d'émission on
vous vous aperçu en train de préparer la
mise en place tout seul comme si aucun
employé ne vous aider au restaurant et
il paraît que la prod vous a demandé sur
l'a2 passé vous même la serpillière pour
montrer que vous étiez seul dans cette
galère
vous aurez même demandé de ne pas
appeler votre extra de d'habitude pour
que l'ambiance du resto puisse être bien
entendu regardez c'est fou que j'arrive
entre 9 heures et 9 heures nuit mais
salariés
déjà ils sont jamais à l'heure et je
fais tout donc je fais la cuisine quand
il fallait cuisine je fais le ménage
quand il fait le ménage lui fait la mise
en place je vais à la déchetterie jvo
course je suis gérante
mais moi de l'ingénerie je trouvais plus
que les samarie alors voilà donc c'est
vrai que mais est-ce que moi moi le truc
c'est ce que vous trouvez ça normal pas
moi ça me choque pas énormément voilà
cauchemar en cuisine et elle l'émission
de tous les dangers on va revenir sur
tout ce qui s'est passé autour de cette
émission vous est-ce que ça ça vous
appellez parce que suite à
l'intervention de des tubes s2 filipetti
regrette le jeune apprenti décide de
démissionner derrière il démissionne
pendant l'émission il démissionne
pendant l'émission évidemment plus il
vient plus en aval et me dit monique je
vais démissionner je lui ai demandé de
me laisser terminer le tournage
et quand on allait voir après qu'on
offrait donc on s'est mis d'accord il
est parti elle a jamais été dit pendant
deux missions évidemment n'aurait pas
démissionné mais oui mais oui alors il
ya quelque chose qui vous a énervé c'est
le fait que philippe etchebest échanger
tout le concept de votre restaurant
avant que vous nous en avons vous en
parliez avec lui on va regarder à
l'image qui s'est passé et ça ça vous a
beaucoup peiné les changements de
concept ça m'a énervé le concept pour
moi il était très bien mais il fallait
peut-être qu'il fasse un étude de marché
pour voir ça marche et chez moi parce
que si vous voyez bien l'émission quand
il arrive moi je les dis que le
restaurant portugais italiens il faut le
faire tourner avec himdi meinau mais
pourquoi vous dites ça vous dites vous
mais pas des plats ils me laissent ne
sais pas s'il mais c'était une question
normal de lui je j'ai vu pendant cinq
jours je le connais pas plus que ça
regardez il a en fait il a complètement
changé le concept du restaurant et du
plat on va faire ensemble c'est de
reprendre un classique de la cuisine
portugaise savoir plus qu à louverné oui
c'est quoi le calme vers des nouvelles c
pour tuer avec pommes de terre des choux
rice et chorizo
c'est une soupe c'est une soupe la c'est
une chance unique qui a appris à faire
il devra je suis très fier de pouvoir
servir ça n'en restera alors ça donc ils
vont changer complètement le concept
wimax in game on voit le prix à payer
cette semaine de se soumettre aussi au
chaud en donner aux codes de la
télévision je rappelle juste quelque
chose lors de la transformation de votre
réseau tout a été pris en charge par la
production en 2016 et ça concernait
aussi les nouveaux équipements la
formation de votre frère paolo
le restaurant a quand même bénéficié
pendant un an des conseils d'une société
rivale l'îlotage d'entreprise il ya
quand même une bénéfice et là dessus on
devient un entretien il ya surtout un
suivi
alors justement rabat on va parler de ça
parce que malheureusement l'émission ne
vous a pas porté lettre que vous vous
attendiez à la fin d'épisode donc
philippe etchebest vous fait découvrir
votre nouvelle carte est votre nouvelle
cuisine et vous n'imaginez pas que cela
va engendrer ce que ça va engendrer par
la suite puisque derrière c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un cauchemar vous avez dû
prendre à votre charge tout le
changement de la devanture du magasin
des nouveaux menus 30000 euros ça vous a
coûté trente mille euros à peu près ces
anciens meubles ont été entreposés dans
un garde-meuble qu'elle devait payer
elle même tous les mois la société garde
meubles ayant fait faillite monica a
perdu tous ses biens ça a été un
enchaînement ça a été vraiment cauchemar
en cuisine pour vous et cauchemars en
dehors vont depuis vous avez vendu votre
restaurant oui oui je les vendrais vie
mais il ya un souci avec la vente aussi
est donc un coup je me trouve
aujourd'hui en dépôt de bilan et
je suis au rsa voilà elle a dû elle
était dans l'impossibilité de rembourser
ses dettes elle touche à présent
seulement le rsa voilà donc c'est vrai
que si j'arrivais à monica voilà donc
c'est vrai que voilà pour vous ça a été
une expérience formidable
comment as-tu d'inpact à pour monica mo
dit qu'est ce que vous avez essayé de
contacter la prod parce que je pense
qu'ils nous regardent ce soit m6 m6
vraiment je vous le dis moi je les aime
ils sont vraiment des gens bien pensants
et nombre d'ont ça je suis persuadé
qu'ils vont essayer de vous aider à ce
que vous avez essayé les contacts et la
neige qui a une chose que je veux
laisser clair avant tout j'ai rien
contre m6
d'accord c'est une équipe extraordinaire
il est là il laissé autant que moi
philippe pour moi c'est quelqu'un de
très authentique well as d'or c'est mon
petit ange les appeler comme ça dans
leurs effets sur le maximum pour vous
oui
après moi je pas là où je pense qu'ils
ont péché aujourd'hui avec le recul
s'est fait refaire un restaurant que
portugais dans la ville où je suis ça ça
m'a tué j' avais pas assez de clients
pour il fallait tenir un an parce que
forcément on en contre avec on voit pas
chamboulé pendant ces contrats quoi que
ce soit parce qu'après ils vont nous
dire oui c'est votre faute n'a pas
marché donc j'ai voulu nous allons tenir
jusqu'à la fin
pendant sept ans cette année et entre
temps j'ai eu aussi ça c'est pas leur
faute j'ai eu des travaux devant la
route ont fermé la route la mairie a pas
voulu minimiser pendant le temps où la
route a été fermée
donc j'ai eu pas mal de situations même
temps que m'ont fait aller dans l'espace
je suis aujourd'hui après je peux pas
coupable ise que filippo l'émission 1
mais je pense que l'effet de nous
changer cette cuisine ça vraiment vous
allez nous dire ce que nous vous demande
m6 dans un instant je vois la réaction
de gilbert des deux matches j'ai
rencontré aujourd'hui j'ai parlé au
téléphone a des jambes brisées et
notamment une dame katic a dû faire un
chantage menacé de se suicider en
appelant la production de mâts raconter
ça aujourd'hui j'en pleurais parce que l
sim pour dix ans de rediffusion
et à force de rediffuser sur son
restaurant quand on voit des produits
avariés ou du dénigrement d'elle c'est
un enfer total donc elle leur a dit si
vous n'arrêtez pas les rediffusions je
vais me suicider voyez comme cette
émission est dangereux et peut briser
ailleurs alors à yassia liliane cette
émission je fais du bien aussi
voilà rien il est sur lui il revient de
très loin grâce à l'émission isabelle
ardon mais alors et ça franchement on
est à la limite du dénigrement je trouve
que c'est grave c'est quand même 60 et
les témoignages
105 moi j'en ai trouvé deux ou 0,15 mais
je les ai qu est ce que vous avez à
demander à m6 ce soir
moi j'aimerais juste qu'ils arrêtent
même des fusées c'est tout vous voulez
plus de diffuser non pourquoi cela vous
porte vraiment préjudice oui parce que
je reçois des messages au quotidien
chaque fois qu'ils allaient la
transmission de l'émission les jugements
et je voulais quand même une fois que
j'ai fermé le restaurant pour les
réseaux que je fermais tourner la page
j'aimerais quand même finir avec tout ça
donc pouvoir voulait tourner la page
vous dites ça des gens vraiment bien et
je suis sûr qu'ils vont entendre votre
appel
et je suis persuadé que legend m6 pour
arrêter de vous diffuser monica voilà
comme sur moi vous aurez réussi à faire
ça et qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
maintenant pour la suite cette ma vie
elle se met en place
c'est tout c'est difficile parce qu'on
entende c'est très difficile se lever
c'est plus long à s'élever qu'à tomber
je vais vous faire un gros bisou parce
que vous êtes magnifique en plus
franchement monica les magnifiques et
sur cd et ben voyons
[Applaudissements]